HAPPY ABOUT THAT ACTION, THEY
CAN TAKE SOLACE THAT WHEN JA DID
NOT PLAY, THEY WERE 20-5 IN
THOSE GAMES.
>> AM I MISSING SOMETHING WHEN I
LOOK AT THE REPLAY IN THIS,
BECAUSE WHEN I LOOK AT IT,
REALLY, THAT IS GOING TO CAUSE A
KNEE INJURY TO CAUSE YOU TO MISS
A GAME?
YOU ARE THE PLAYERS AND TELL ME.
>> NOT ONLY THAT, BUT IS IT THE
MCL, LCL, KNEECAP -- WHAT?
>> THAT IS JUST UNFORTUNATE, BUT
I THINK.
>> HYPEREXTENSION, AND THE
EXTENSION OF THE PLAY RIGHT
BEFORE HE GRABBED IT IS REALLY,
PROBABLY WITH THE OUTSTRETCHED,
GRAB, AND YOU KNOW --
>> YOU THINK IT HAPPENED BEFORE?
>> IT LOOKS LIKE POOLE GRABBED
IT, BUT IF YOU ARE LOOKING AT
IT, HE KIND OF RIGHT HERE TO ME,
THAT WOULD CAUSE MORE THAN WHAT
POOLE DID WITH THAT MOTION.
>> OKAY.
>> THAT IS GOING TO BE IT.
>> STOP IT.
WE ARE GETTING OUT OF HAND RIGHT
NOW.
AND AND WE CAN DO NOTHING WITH
IT.
>> THAT IS A STRUCTURALLY STRONG
KNEE TO DO ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
>> YOU WANT THE TRY IT.
>> COME ON, KENNY.
KENNY, GO AHEAD.
>> DO IT AGAIN?
>> DO IT ONE MORE TIME.
>> NO, THAT IS GOOD.
>> LIKE I SAID.
>> IF YOU DO IT ONE MORE TIME,
HE IS GOING TO MISS THE SHOW
TOMORROW.
>> DO IT FROM THAT ANGLE THERE.
>> ONE MORE TIME.
>> I WAS GOING TO RACE YOU TO
THE BOARD.
>> ONE MORE TIME.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO.
>> OH, NO.
WE ARE GOOD.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT ANY OF THAT
WAS, BUT KEEP IN MIND WHAT ERIC
GREENBERG SAID AT THE END OF
THAT, THE GRIZZLIES WHEN JA
DIDN'T PLAY THIS YEAR, THEY WERE
20-5.
>> EDWARD SCISSORHANDS.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> CHUCK D.
>> AND YOU TAKE FOR GRANTED THE
FLAWLESS GREATNESS OF THE NBA ON
TNT AND THE CREW, AND THE BEST
OF THEM ALL.
AND HEY.
>> CHUCK D, YOU ARE THE MAN.
THANK YOU FOR THE ALBUM, AND I
BOUGHT ME A BRAND-NEW RECORD
PLAYER.
>> A RECORD PLAYER?
WI?
>> BECAUSE HE SENT ME THE VINYL.
>> OH, THAT